you know like I don't know if any of you
ended up like ever hooking up or
marrying your best friend but not that
not that I'm not oh no no no no we we
actually hooked up which it's not best
friend tell me I was going to start
natural way I'm Tom Geisel I kind of bag
right come around acting like a visible
and active Authority hustle my my name
is Gary Sabah [ __ ] I've been
telling you
challenges talk about yeah I'm triple-a
Canada pedigree I mean in a pleasure my
faculty are putting the work that I'm
doing are the moving furniture that's a
great question first of all and I think
you'll love this within my organization
and what and I assume here but like it's
a younger company we haven't had this
talk
winning first of all is very individual
like the most interesting thing for me
is actually understanding what everybody
in this room thinks winning is for
themselves so that we can reverse
engineer it that's where I spent all my
time on I don't give a [ __ ] if you want
to buy the Jets or if you want to make
one hundred thirty seven thousand
dollars a year have ridiculously good
work-life balance still keep a job when
you started with a battle it's
unbelievable how much I care and how
much I don't care about what winning
means to you meaning I'd massively care
and then you get to define it for me
it's just about the journey of building
businesses it is my drug it is my oxygen
I love it I love that I love this
journey because I want to see how we
stack up with me involved against the
other people that are trying to capture
the attention and so in essence what it
is is one big game of how do I provide
the most value so in return I get the
attention that I see
I'd like to get together just wait I
feel like there need to be dramatically
more communication to the table with
this small group and so I think for all
of you individually it's a good thought
to think about when it's on your
schedule over the weekend like maybe the
one or two things you want to bring it
up of like closer and cause I'm never
going to be strong in like having a core
agenda maybe the office CEO can take
that over for me over time but I think
it's you know for me it's just good to
get us aligned a lot of when I look back
in the last six months a lot of times
things are happening in pockets of two
or four six or a and I think this will
give us an opportunity to do that and
then opportunity to talk about things
that are important so that's what I'd
like to do more often I mean that to me
that's the big thing whether I want to
make sure we're over delivering on the
quality for it and like start really
having conversations of what can studio
do what like how do we how do we
replicate you know like like lighter it
the entire market is recognizing it
let's understand what's actually
happening here like at the macro all the
sudden after we do these two things like
people believe like only actions make
you believe like right like the reason
I've been pretty passive is like I'm not
willing to look at rhetoric I want to
look at actions and then what action is
happening you have to make your
decisions right like we are really
really really dangerous and very
excitingly close serious so ma'am
yes I think the biggest moving labor is
figuring out how we get in horrible
because global creating all the content
right now and we're good yeah well we'll
figure out that on your neck will play
itself out in that day there's actually
a lot on my on we're going to throw a
lot of into your guys pod I want to
really scratch you and Lisa yeah because
I just want to bet on both of you and I
want to kind of help you I want to speed
your process and next levels so this is
like it goes away you may get six new
things
that's about you'll see bad and we'll
just continue to see things so it's got
it I just keep that on a macro yeah look
look how well my teacher strategies
works man [ __ ] queer holy I'm Kaylen
I am a VP Group Account Director on a
few of our large CPG friends here at
Vayner I've been here for almost five
years
he found the biggest piece of advice I
got from Gary was a few months being at
dinner I was kind of used to PR where
you were constantly on a lot of
different brands on a lot of campaigns
I'm at the time I was really only on one
brand for six months straight and I kind
of gone to him expressing the desire to
be on multiple things and he basically
told me he shipped contributors and I
think you know that there's value in
doing one thing consistently I'm getting
better at that one thing over time I
think he's right and so we were kind of
joking about how is it for you
Phaethon scare advantage the color key
block want some updates on dailyvee now
so here it is I'm workin d-roc got your
update I did a meeting with my
leadership team I did a meeting with
resi the restaurant maps at all you
should be using I did a meeting with a
couple individuals that run key accounts
stopped in hello and said hello to a
candidate what I did for the last couple
hours
so when I think about dailyvee I always
wonder like you know 20g rock remember
when we started this like the fourth or
sixth or ninth day episode you were like
and this is one we're going to do it two
or three times a week you're like how
are we going to come up with different
stuff and so like it's clearly worked
out but I'd be remiss to not tell you
these are my favorite days just a good
old fashioned I'm in New York I'm the
CEO of this company I talk to you guys a
lot about like Gary Vee being my side
hustle we are debating very aggressively
on a daily basis how do we show you more
things we're trying to do that but even
today like already hard like just had a
major client meeting was very
inappropriate meeting a new very senior
client and I'm empathetic that me
rolling and not only with like camera
guy that we're doing some still shops
today as well like that's a douche a
[ __ ] about her like you know that could
go over very poorly and and so we need
to be empathetic for it I love when
we're like seeing athletes or rappers or
or we're going to be in some cool
settings
I'm sure still think you should come to
Super Bowl so one can you we now I know
because you know but you can come Friday
I'm sorry
well that's the only time I'm going to
be there you'll just leave Saturday
afternoon yeah done knocking it it
doesn't [ __ ] you up I mean it it'll be
fine
awesome mo man okay you can leave early
Saturday and I'll do the rest
cool see this is how we roll anyway
where did I go swimming cool things like
Super Bowl and like famous people and
they'll be a lot more as playing the
apps comes out and I actually become
more mainstream no Tura you know
recognize them more things live we have
an amazing dinner with like a very
all-time classic rapper so everybody
super mad that I'm only focusing on the
new stuff old stuffs coming but nothing
Trump's nothing gets me going more than
a solid Monday with a shitload of
business meetings where I'm executing
and delivering on being the CEO of you
know a nine figure business this is in
[ __ ] kindergarten and more so just
thought I tell you that's my like
executing I like doing the work I like
eating my own dog food when I tell you
guys to be something it's only after I
did it already that's the problem that
pisses me off so much some can literally
emailed me and said Gary need your help
I want to learn more about social media
dcs this was insane I need your help and
advice on how to be doing social how to
do social media because I started a
social media agency so I literally
replied to him what do I reply like are
you charging people I'm like are you
charging people he goes he goes yes I'm
just like laughing I'm like I'm like
that's like me charging for skiing
lessons and hitting up somebody and
asking them to learn how to ski because
I can't ski look at [ __ ]
[Music]
oh well good stuff so mad
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk CEO let go I don't
like little density or like fix the well
dr. Rafat
fix the well not the sink every time
it's great a fit that's it let me give
you the manifesto on that a lot of the
things I'm going to be the bottleneck so
what I would say is office of the CEO
should really probably right up be very
close to the write up of all these other
things because they're the closest to
probably knowing where I said honest
things are creative down and then Jason
of Marin if you got video down like I
feel comfortable there but like all
these other things so let me give an
example solutions I want to leave the
dog to the well right like like I want
to basically say we are often asked to
help with digital work where the budget
doesn't match the need of the amount of
creative output for that we have found
over the last five years one of the
great services we can provide for our
clients is creating a digital
architecture and framework how to be
successful in the modern mobile world
the other the review right now my
intuition on the ninety percent
wholesale what we do best
what your company needs most let me give
you let us present to you maybe tomorrow
right duck maybe once maybe two days but
no more than two answers yes
Wednesday latest how we do influencer
why we've been winning with blood wiser
and Panasonic and others and how we
would attack this because Facebook
commercials are more expensive and
complicated because you get into
creative paid media amplification why
don't we go over
there's less politics right now and let
us come with an influencer campaign for
you America how are you no pleasure yeah
I think glad we got the connect this is
not too shabby you've been on up yet
tell me what's going on your world man
and how you're thinking about it yeah so
I graduate
here we go then full-time making videos
for a year I was doing it alongside
school for all the previous six seven
years yeah yeah yeah so this is just
been like an evolution of making videos
about texts and summer electronics
reviews explanations all that anything
which is by the way so weird for me
because that's the world I walked into
when I started Wine Library TV in 2006
the only videos online where that
iJustine diggnation like you know like
tekzilla Leo Laporte and that's where
you were influenced but yeah yeah put
your energy and forces behind pushing
them to YouTube if that's where you
decide the right places
you have zero downside of the
distribution
there's the entire universe is living on
Facebook as well and there's just no
downside so here's what I would say you
know it's easy when you eat your own dog
food
hi care less about hitting the vanity
metric of how many views on YouTube I
have I care about the net impact of the
brand I'm creating so to me if you ask
me what's better one million YouTube
videos and zero Facebook or eight
hundred forty-seven thousand YouTube
videos and 347,000 you're going to
you're going to win that game not to
mention when you start thinking about
real economics like where you're really
going to get into real money so it's one
of things that people one of the reasons
a lot of people come here is if you
really look at like the people that come
and visit me and I hang with so many of
them have way more followers than me but
the economics I'm able to create are far
greater because that's how I think about
stuff when you think about who's going
to consume randomly your Facebook videos
they're the people that are going to
write the bigger checks they're gonna be
the people that are going to come out
and say here's a three million dollar
sponsorship deal that just matters and
in a youtube environment you've got to
go to it in a facebook environment it
comes to you well I can tell you for
sure is you don't have to pick either or
99% of the time there's so much
fragmentation of attention you can't
leave the overexposure the way that
people think good creators are romantic
and are calculated around their art and
I do think that you can do both I'm not
good-looking due to any have any time
everybody carries a mugshot and it's a
240 and we asked guarantee show if you
want people to give the influencers and
you want them to come on so they bring
their audience you've lost we will walk
through how much you're getting the
musical equity in your company
you've lost everybody it's a chicken
around gates arrest you know like
everybody wants you want influencers
because you want them to bring the
million people that pay attention to
them over and sign up for your world no
matter how much economics you give them
you're you're getting more than you're
giving them in that first move which
means you'll never get started
you have to solve for that you don't
actually do it all but when you aspire
to do it all you just get to a lot more
of it than if you don't I mean right
like like like like if I decide I'm
going to run right now out of this car
to California like that is the goal and
mission of my life I can't have a funny
feeling that I'm going to run further
than somebody saying I'm going to run
down the block this is you are so like I
think people are too perfect and too
refined and are scared to lose because
of who I started with if they care about
what other people think I don't care
at vaynermedia went out of business what
you would say ah see I knew it
you suck no I'm going to rise like a
phoenix and stick it in your mouth
it's an important insight and I'm glad
you're responding to it the way you are
because it's a big deal like I like
losing because I'm not willing to factor
you in to the equation and for me losing
is going to teach me what not to do
again
hey I'm getting upgrade yeah if we
wouldn't do this
and we were to do it well we do the
number one rib in one year it's that big
like ruling dead that's what I've always
been good at whatever lose things good
at is never taking the last medium and
putting into the new medium right that's
where people lose like if you look at
the first 100 commercials they were all
radio ads so obvious that I think it's
been so hard warming to think how many
people here feel comfortable with what's
happening now I mean really very honest
if you've given that I think I've sealed
here before theoretically I'd love to do
as much QA as possible right now to like
really like I'll give you a couple of
top-line thoughts and I'd love to answer
any questions if you're wondering about
like how I think about things or from my
lens and show Ryan's giving you a lot of
his stuff you know but I think that the
media landscape is going to go through a
substantial change more so than already
has over the last decade and I'm sure
for a lot of you if you work here you
understand what that means in the scheme
of things
I couldn't imagine progressing my career
with not getting into the pure media
side of things but I think I can have a
bigger impact then the companies I
invest in or things of that nature and
so I'm excited to get to meet a lot of
you and interact and take this journey
together and I want you know to me when
you sell a company that [ __ ] is scary
what you know what's been most
interesting to me has this got close
after we had such a fun like we had like
that was such a great meeting for me I
don't know what I don't know how was for
you but you know for me it was like so
warm and so line and great question I'm
so good
I remember thinking [ __ ] if this happens
they're going to feel safe and pumped
and so that excited me and I want to
deliver on that intuitive feeling that I
think a lot of young there was a lot of
words that could have come out of Ryan's
mouth of like hey we've sold to that I'm
sure for many of you you've been
debating in your mind if it happens and
I know for a fact that's the majority of
the things that ran through your mind of
where this company could be sold to were
far less interesting than what we're
about to be up to and so that excites me
so that's my spiel cool thanks for
having me see you soon
simply click cool silly what but like
but what I do know is if you own that
and you editorially executed it well
that the upside is so great when you
talk about the way I think about things
it's similar to me after I gave you a
lot of what's going to come out of my
mind is if this hits it changes
everything and I'm okay to go 1 for 5
because 1 for 5 is net positive and I
believe the world goes over oh and
that's just my general kind if you
understand where I think like as a macro
I think the world goes over oh because
people say nice and safe do what they do
never push it because they're scared of
going oh you know missing because it's
expensive it took time with opportunity
costs to me we are now in a place
financially infrastructurally that we
should try to do the ambitions that
maybe some of you have on different
things as well and the other thing is
back to the point I call like you should
sponsor this or more and they're like
okay thank you is also that part by the
way everybody's thinking about the one
version of the thing they'd want to do
that they don't do it's amazing when
people are allowed to do that I like the
hustle meter goes through the roof if
you're actually doing [ __ ] that you want
to do like you like for some of you
creatively you're probably more than
happy to do exactly what you're doing
and do this thing as long as you're just
allowed to do the thing and you'll do
that plenty afterwards because you just
want to see the creators you want to
bring it to life you know curious you
are if it would work you know what I
like about I'm just curious I'm real
curious I also know it's the kind of
thing that leads us to writing the
number one book in America because I
know that's where all the action is and
God forbid we stumble
something you think NPR knew that
[ __ ] podcasts were going to save
their business promise you they did it
but if they didn't try they would have
never known
[Music]
no [ __ ] but law this is ready for this
that's this is a macro version of what I
just told your editorial staff because
we're in the yes business waiting over
the [ __ ] you just kept getting to a
place for like wait a minute
[Music]
[Music]
bye guys have a great night kissa
pleasure take care see you later
bye guys bye great to see you
I'm very night make sure if anybody ever
feels like like it's very possible that
you could have 39 things and you can
have seven in six months like we need be
smart about yeah good thank you join us
yeah for me it's just about the journey
of building businesses it is my drug it
is my oxygen I love it I love that I
love this journey because I want to see
how we stack up with me involved against
the other people that are trying to
capture the attention and so in essence
what it is is one big game of how do I
provide the most value so in return I
get the attention that I seek
[Music]
a cattle I build the best building the
best company for the people in it and
for the people that are consuming it
which then creates a byproduct of it
becoming this standard and even more
interesting how do I change businesses I
love setting the rules of industries it
was so fun for me to change the wine
business which was a business that's on
the lower price point there were low
margins but on premium wine over $30
there was all the margin I came in and
broke that and I love the legacy of
changing an industry I love that so for
me winning comes in two forms
just building very very very large
businesses I call it honey
empires right how I build a honey Empire
how do I build unbelievably successful
massive businesses in a honey way the
right way that's good for everybody
involved
internally first an externally second
and then if I can leave a legacy that we
changed it like if my Wikipedia says oh
and then he went into this business and
now everybody does it this way that's
super interesting to me like breaking
[ __ ] and reinventing it has legacy I
like the legacy of it
[Music]